it's fair to say at this point that the
threat of the
chinese government spying on you just
isn't enough to put people off
the wonderful world of tick-tock
[Music]
and even though there's no evidence to
say that tick tock is working for the
chinese
authorities it is still spying on you
even if you don't have a tick tock
account
do you remember when facebook was
slammed for creating profiles for people
who hadn't even created
an account i'm not familiar with that so
zuckerberg denies that they exist
but when have we ever taken zuckerberg's
word for it so now tick tock is doing
exactly the same so if you thought you'd
outsmarted tick tock by
binging on its content anonymously
you'd be wrong an article advice has
revealed that tiktok can identify you
from your ip address mobile carrier
and time zone it even knows what device
you use
it's screen resolution telephone
operator
and operating system a journalist from
vice
made this discovery after asking tik tok
for all of the data that the app had on
him
and he was very surprised to find out
that even if you don't have an account
tick tock keeps a database of the videos
you've watched
when you watch them time spent on the
app
to the second any actions you've taken
and everything else down to the finest
details
so essentially if you're doing any
accountless browsing
it's not very secret and guess what
you may have thought that they were arch
enemies but tick tock
actually shares your data with facebook
just check your off facebook activity
in facebook settings you could always
join a tribe and
live in the amazon oh
or maybe not